[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تقع البلدان العربيه في نطاق العروض
الجغرافيه الذي يتقارب فيها طول الليل مع
النهار ويتقلب فيهما بين الطول والقصر
ومكان وزمان شروق وهروب الشمس يتغير فيهما
الا في يومين يوم الاعتدال الربيعي ويوم
الاعتدال الخريفي 16 مارس و27 سبتمبر
فخلال هذين اليومين تشرق وتغرب الشمس في
نفس موعدها وتشرق من المشرق تماما وتغرب
من المغرب تماما ويعتدل فيها الزمان لو
كنت كالقدح في التقويمي معتدلا لقالت
الناس وهذا غير معتدله شر الوراء بمساو
الناس يشتغل مثل الذباب يراعي
موضع العللي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام تعيش الدول العربيه
الوقت الابكر لغروب الشمس ويستمر هذا
التبكير طوال هذا الاسبوع واقصى وقت
الغروب الشمس عليها ب 22 يونيو وابكر وقت
لشروقها في ثماني واقصى وقت لشروقها
باربعه يناير ويتزامل ذلك مع الحضيض الارض
وهي اقرب مسافه بين الارض والشمس فلا اقسم
برب المشارق والمغارب انا لقادرون على ان
نبدل خيرا منهم ما نحن
[موسيقى]